foreign
trillion years from now the last of a
great civilization Heights in the
Darkness
throughout their Glory Days their
Engineers worked entire star systems
they dismantled planets and asteroids to
construct an immense Interstellar Empire
but now in the Twilight of their time
all of this is long gone
all around them the universe is dying as
the last of the stars are going out over
countless Millennia the sky has
continued to fade into an eternal night
the Aging Universe gripped by desolation
and decay
and so in the Darkness
they wait for the end
long before they had realized it was
coming they knew that the Universe was
on a path of inevitable decline
methodically they hunted for a final
place to wait out eternity and embarked
on their last great feat of engineering
around a lost and lonely black hole they
built a new home with demolished worlds
as raw materials they constructed a
shell to completely enclose the darkness
and within this thin shell barely
withstanding the gravitational grip of
their savior they eked out their meager
lives
the dwindling light of dying Stars
rained down upon their final home whilst
their swirling black hole was harvested
to power their existence
but more than that the black hole at
their hearts gave them the greatest gift
of all for the black hole
gave them time
[Music]
no one remembered the name of the great
scientist who had discovered the nature
of time but the Astro Engineers knew
that time was not the same across the
cosmos and here within the immense
gravity of the black hole time trickled
more slowly whilst many years passed
outside mere moments flashed by within
the immense sphere and so the last of
the civilization watched the future play
out in front of them
but they knew they had only delayed not
averted their ultimate demise
and the Darkness would inevitably
envelop them
forever
of course this story is little more than
speculation
but it is built on a scientific idea
that changed our universe
it's been more than a century since
Einstein's relativity shook up our
understanding of time and space but how
does it really work
and what does it really mean
both time and space seems so commonplace
so obvious so every day but beneath
their ubiquity they hide a multitude of
unanswered questions questions to which
Einstein's theories only begin to answer
[Music]
what is space made of
does time exist and Will Hunting for
their ultimate nature lead to sudden
Clarity all space and time just become
more
elusive
[Music]
Einstein offered them lunch and they
accepted so he moved a whole bunch of
papers from the table opened four cans
of beans with a can opener heated them
stuck a spoon in each and that was our
lunch Albert Einstein was a busy man and
often missed lunch and that was back in
1915 in the century since our lives have
only become more chaotic and that is why
a meal kids service like hellofresh our
sponsors today are such a great choice
hellofresh delivers fresh high quality
produce straight from the farm to your
door with more than 55 weekly meal
options great for everyone and
especially if you want to stay fit and
healthy I'm a big fan of fitness and
eating the right food but in honesty
sometimes there just aren't enough hours
in the day and a microwavable meal seems
like the only option hellofresh has
saved me from this tasteless horror the
kits are foolproof genuinely really hard
to get wrong and that is coming from an
absolute cooking disaster and last but
definitely not least a recent survey
found their meals up to 72 cheaper than
dining out or grocery shopping go to
hellofresh.com and use the code history
16 for up to 16 free meals and three
surprise gifts this is a great company
and the cherry on top is that they're
also carbon neutral a big thanks to
hellofresh for supporting educational
content on YouTube
[Music]
as the Lonely World lingered on its
Beating Heart warped the very fabric of
the universe around it
the civilization had done everything
they could to keep going to put off the
inevitable
tries they might they could only Bend
reality they could not
break it
behind it all is surely an idea so
simple so beautiful that when we grasp
it in a decade a century or a millennium
we will all say to each other how could
it have been otherwise how could we have
been so stupid
what is space
the question seems almost meaningless as
children we learn to describe our
surroundings as up down left right back
and front we called it three-dimensional
and are free to explore each Dimension
but just what is it this Universal
platform on which we play out our lives
it is a question that occupied the minds
of the earliest philosophers in the 4th
Century BC Plato declared that space was
the nurse of becoming a medium in which
everything existed but with no qualities
of its own and his student Aristotle
agreed that an empty void was impossible
but it would be more than 2 000 years
before our concept of space was born by
the coming of the 17th century modern
science was crystallizing the processes
of the universe were being codified into
physical laws and the understanding of
these physical laws was evolving from
myths and stories to the language of
mathematics of course Isaac Newton was
at the Forefront of this revolution but
before he enters our stage we must first
start
with the boat
in 1632 Galileo published his seminal
work dialogue concerning the Two Chief
World Systems he was in his mid-60s by
this point and had already had multiple
run-ins with the Roman Inquisition for
his assertions that the Earth rotated
around the Sun so he decided to skirt
controversy and spend the intervening
years quietly cementing his Myriad ideas
on space and the cosmos into a book
and at one point within this book he
Muses on a boat
more specifically the life of a sailor
looked below deck in a windowless cabin
with plates knives and a goldfish in a
bowl on the table and a collection of
Birds flies and butterflies just what
does this say that experience
tied up in Port the cabin is a picture
of Serenity all is calm as the Goldfish
swims happily in his bowl on the table
pleats and Cutlery remain in their place
and the flying creatures happily flutter
about but finding itself in rough Seas
the cabin heaves and falls with the ship
plates and Cutlery are wrenched off the
table water spills from the Goldfish
Bowl on calm seas with wind-filled sails
the ship would speed up the Sailor would
feel this change and see things sliding
off the table but when the wind finally
drops the Ship Sails smoothly on the
glassy sea inside the cabin all would be
calm Serenity returning
for the Sailor it would be as if the
ship was still in Port and was not
moving at all a dropped plate would fall
straight to the floor and the Sailor
would sit comfortably in their chair
and it was here Galileo realized
something
without a window to reveal the truth
there are no experiments the Sailor
could do to reveal whether the ship was
moving or not he concluded therefore
that there must be no absolute concept
of being at rest in space instead
everyone must experience any smooth
uniform motion in the same way all
uniform motion must feel like simply
being still
Galileo declared that any uniform motion
is simply relative to any other uniform
motion
and with this the first theory of
relativity
had been born
Galileo's sailor floats gently on their
ship on Seas near the earth's equator
rotating at 1600 kilometers an hour
around the earth which in turn orbits
the Sun at 67 000 kilometers an hour
which in turn orbits the Milky Way at
720 000 kilometers an hour which in turn
is traveling towards the Andromeda
galaxy at 403
000 kilometers an hour
and yet he feels nothing on this vast
Journey millions of kilometers from his
starting point
[Music]
unfortunately upon publishing the book
Galileo once again fell foul of the
church and was found guilty of heresy
for his heliocentric view of the cosmos
the work was banned and would not be
removed from the church's index of
forbidden books until 1835.
but this was not the end for within a
few Decades of Galileo's downfall two of
Europe's greatest Minds were arguing
about the nature of space one of them
Isaac Newton was born in England in 1642
within a year of Galileo's death he of
course needs little introduction and is
known now as one of the greatest
thinkers of his age perhaps one of the
greatest of all time and was not
forgotten his opponent Gottfried leibniz
is somewhat less well known today
born in 1646 in what is present-day
Germany he was a leading thinker of his
time writing on mathematics and
philosophy he pondered deep metaphysical
questions including one that still
haunts physicists and philosophers to
this day why there is something rather
than nothing it was in the development
of calculus that the two men's Feud
began whilst leibniz published his work
first Newton claimed that he had stolen
his ideas as president of the Royal
Society at the time Newton set up a
committee to investigate the dispute
unsurprisingly the committee found in
favor of Newton and so this animosity
carried over to their second
disagreement
simple question
what happens to a spinning bucket of
water
space Newton declared was a universal
absolute a rigid stage on which motion
was played out and both space and time
would exist in a universe devoid of
matter to experience any motion to argue
his point Newton asked us to think about
a bucket of water if the bucket sits at
rest the surface of the water would be
flat and level but if we spin the bucket
the water spins too and its surface
becomes curved and so Newton asked just
what is the water spinning with respect
to he claimed that the acceleration of
the spin was relative to an absolute
space something separate to the object
itself and so spinning a bucket in an
empty Universe would also curve the
surface of the water
but to leibniz space in an empty
Universe devoid of any matter simply
made no sense the properties of objects
leibniz claimed are essential in
defining their meaning space only had
meaning in the relative locations of
objects and similarly time only had
meaning when discussing their relative
motions without matter leibniz said
space and time simply had no role and
hence
no existence
[Music]
sadly leibniz died in 1716 with the
argument still in full swing and it was
Newton's ideas that stuck absolute space
in its own nature without relation to
anything external remains always similar
and immovable absolute true and
mathematical time of itself and from its
own nature flows equally without
relation to anything external
this so-called absolute space and time
would be the accepted science for nearly
two centuries but with the caveat of
Galileo's rejection of absolute rest
relativity was still part of the
argument
but that only applied to space
time was a totally different matter with
its implicit Direction time appeared
completely distinct for Newton and
Galileo everyone's clock Across the
Universe ticked with absolute
synchronicity a universal beat that ran
through every event in the cosmos one
second on Earth the same as a second
anywhere else
for this this true is time malleable or
an unswerving metronome that drags the
cosmos forward does time itself have
Properties or is it defined only by the
events that run in its current
to answer these questions we must begin
not with physicists wondering about
clocks rulers and motion
but with heat
in the distant future Universe around
the Aging black hole our dying
civilization sits and waits for sitting
and waiting is all they can do
with the passing of the Stars raw energy
had become the most precious thing to
preserve what they had they had slowed
their very existence
every aspect was focused upon survival
as their sleepy eyes watched the ever
darkening Skies
total Universal heat death crept across
the cosmos
they realized the time was their
Ultimate Enemy
oh
you may see a cup of tea fall off a
table and break into pieces on the floor
but you will never see the cup gather
itself back together and jump back on
the table
foreign
[Music]
like space the nature of time occupied
the minds of many ancient thinkers in
ancient Greece Aristotle stated that
time was simply the steps between before
and after whilst Hindu philosophers saw
time as cyclical from creation to
destruction over four billion years but
its true origin remained elusive
like space time seems to be something
obvious something that is just present
but it is clearly a different Beast we
cannot for example freely travel through
time unlike space time has a direction a
distinct past and a coming future of
course scientists can be pragmatic and
not worry about the nature of time
coupled with a ruler a clock completes
the experiment as toolbox but it doesn't
mean we can ignore the question
and so to understand time fully we first
have to think about horses and steam
engines
the coming of the Industrial Revolution
presented Humanity with a problem the
original engines of civilization draft
animals like horses and cattle were
relatively simple things understanding
how much to feed them and how much to
work them was easy a certain number of
bales of hay could guarantee a day's
work from a well-fed animal
but what of newfangled machines such as
a steam engine how much work can you get
out of a heap of coal this was an
important question from an economic
standpoint do you even bother to replace
a horse with an engine if it is going to
cost more to feed it and it was out of
this conundrum that thermodynamics was
born
many mines were wrestling over the
question of the ultimate efficiency of
engines indeed at the time of
thermodynamics Inception a typical
engine only worked at three percent
efficiency in a physical steam engine
the heat of the fire is used to boil
water but some of the fire's heat just
radiates into the air metal scrapes
against metal screeching loud and hot to
the touch both forms of energy loss in
any physical steam engine this loss of
heat as waste is inevitable and indeed
within the mathematics of thermodynamics
perfect efficiency was found to be an
illusion the concentrated energy
released from burning coal must be
degraded as it flows through the engine
and some must be lost into the
surroundings
eventually a new measure was introduced
to account for this increase of Decay
and disorder
entropy and it is probability that
dictates how this happens
as the early 20th century physicist
George gamof put it the room in which
you sit reading this book is filled
uniformly by air from wall to wall and
from floor to ceiling and it never even
occurs to you that the air in the room
can unexpectedly collect itself in a far
Corner leaving you to suffocate in your
chair however this horrifying event is
not at all physically impossible but
only highly improbable
gamoth goes on to give the waiting time
of such an event trillions upon
trillions of times longer than the
entire age of the universe
disorder is always statistically far
more likely
and so through these new laws of
thermodynamics physicists revealed an
inexorable growth in entropy as the
universe marches on a future Universe
destined to be more disordered and
decayed than today's and this applied
not only to steam engines but whole
planets Stars galaxies filaments all
marching from order
to disorder
it was in 1862 that the Grim logical
endpoint of these ideas was proposed by
Lord Kelvin For Whom the measurement
unit was named although mechanical
energy is indestructible there is a
universal tendency to its dissipation
which produces exhaustion of potential
energy through the material Universe the
result would inevitably be a state of
universal rest and death if the universe
were finite and left to obey existing
laws
and so was this time a constantly dying
Universe heading for inevitable heat
death stars going out one by one in a
steady March from potential energy to
waste leaving the trillion-year-old
universe dark and spent
one of the great minds to occupy himself
with entropy and the arrow of time was
James Clark Maxwell the iconic Scottish
19th century scientist his views on
thermodynamics shaped our understanding
of heat and gases and he did all of this
with the assistance of a demon
Maxwell understood the implications of
entropy he knew that if he mixed two
gases one hot and one cold the result
would be warm gas and he knew that the
gas would stay warm and mixed rather
than separating into two halves
but he wondered what if we introduced a
tiny demon who can sense each and every
atom in the gas this demon can turn
around atoms directing slow atoms to one
side and fast to the other as the
temperature of a gas is a reflection of
the average speed of its atoms the demon
could effectively separate the warm gas
into two unequal halves one hot and one
cold the demon seems to have broken the
laws of thermodynamics it is taken the
disordered State the warm gas and
created a more ordered State hot and
cold gas and whilst this is only a
thought experiment arguments over the
meaning of Maxwell's demon have raged
for over 150 years some have stated that
the demon must be expending energy to
sort the gas atoms and so total entropy
will continue to rise however some have
proposed that it is not energy
important but the fact that the demon
uses information namely the speeds of
the atoms to do the Sorting linking
energy entropy and information might
seem a little strange but over the last
three quarters of a century this link
has become stronger and stronger and as
any Touch of a computer will tell you
processing information generates a lot
of waste heat but the situation is even
more complex than that for it is not
simply the processing of information
that leads to waste Heat
forgetting when we add three and two the
answer is of course five but if I told
you an answer was five and ask what two
numbers are sum together you cannot
answer
in a similar way inside a computer logic
gates combine electronic signals to do
the addition whilst two numbers are fed
in they are forgotten as the single
answer is spat out the calculation is
irreversible the inputs lost to the
universe
and in the action of forgetting the
logic gates heat up
still little
in this way thermodynamics provides us
with the ultimate limit for forgetting
called the land hour limit it is the
inevitable release of energy from
erasing a single bit of information and
at room temperature it is just over one
hundredth of an electron volt
proven experimentally in 2012 scientists
believe that at present computer chips
produce thousands of times more heat
than this limit but by 2035 they will
most likely reach it that tiny bit of
waste heat inescapably increasing the
entropy of the universe
ultimately across the cosmos it is this
irreversibility of calculations that
drives entropy to increase
forgetting information is therefore an
essential ingredient for defining an
arrow of time
does this mean that for yesterday and
tomorrow to have meaning we must forget
is the existence of the future
implicitly tied to our inability to
remember
and it is now we can return to our
lonely civilization on the brink of
universal heat death in the far distant
future
when all useful energy is used up and
entropy is at maximum would time even
have any meaning
[Music]
and so we have now reached a turning
point
the foundations of modern time and space
can only get us so far and though they
are useful there is another Revolution
coming a new order that will lead
directly to the last days of our lonely
black hole world and as we continue in
our journey we are going to have to
explore new time
and a new space
[Music]
within their black hole shell many of
the civilization resigned themselves to
their fate and dosed their way to the
end
but a few curious minds with their
dwindling energy still wondered about
the universe great books that had
existed for almost an eternity told them
how space could Bend and curve
Central to these books was the story of
light they knew that light speed was
immense and had used it to help measure
their empire they knew that light was a
limit they could never break no matter
how hard they tried
and they knew that the speed of light
had been the first step in the long
journey to understanding How the
Universe
really worked
when you are next out of doors on a
summer night turn your head towards the
Zenith almost vertically above you will
be shining the brightest star of the
northern Skies Vega of the liar 26 years
away at the speed of light near enough
to the point of no return for us
short-lived creatures for no man will
ever turn homewards Beyond Vega to greet
again those he knew and loved on Earth
the speed of light has always been
mysterious early experiments in flashing
lights back and forth had shown that it
must be much faster than sound so
scientists wondered was it infinite in
speed
it was in 1676 that Danish astronomer
olly Roma finally found the answer Roma
was observing the moons of Jupiter as
they circled the giant planet and timing
just when they entered the gas Giant's
planetary Shadow he had assumed that the
orbits ticked like clockwork and so
would be able to predict just when the
eclipses of the moons would begin and
end but as he observed the moon IO
throughout the year his predictions got
steadily worse and then better again it
became clear that the accuracy of his
predictions depended upon our distance
to Jupiter and he would need to include
the extra time taken by light having to
travel further and so with Roma's data
fellow astronomer Christian hikens
calculated that light must move at more
than 200 and 11
000 kilometers every second not far off
our modern estimate of about 300 000
Roma's observation confirmed that light
was fast and finite but precisely what
light was walls would have to wait for
two centuries for as well as the
confusing implications of James Clark
Maxwell's demon he is also famous for
intertwining electricity and magnetism
into a single idea
electromagnetism
light he found was nothing more than a
self-propagating combination of the two
and written into these equations was
light's blistering speed but there was
still a problem just what was this speed
relative to Maxwell's equations gave no
answers so physicists began to search
for a solution perhaps they hypothesized
light traveled in an invisible medium a
mysterious ether permeating the entire
Cosmos
but that would also imply an ultimate
state of rest in the universe a worrying
thought as this would break Galileo's
relativity the problem was severe so
whilst one group of physicists set out
to measure the properties of this
supposed ether others took the evidence
in front of them and made an even larger
leap
and chief among these was a young Albert
Einstein
[Music]
Einstein wondered why electricity and
magnetism would not obey Galileo's
relativity why should experiments
specifically using the flow of
electricity or spin of a magnet reveal
absolute Motion in a bold step he
declared that they cannot
and with that the special theory of
relativity was born
on Galileo's ship Einstein proposed all
experiments would yield the same results
whether the ship was secured in port or
smoothly saving on a glassy sea throwing
a ball would of course not reveal
whether the ship was moving but neither
would measuring the speed of light
the speed of light in a vacuum was
constant this final statement seemed to
fly in the face of the universe as laid
out by Newton in Newtonian mechanics you
could simply add speeds together and
each Observer would measure differing
speeds dependent on their own motion but
according to Einstein this was not the
case for light everyone would measure
the same speed whether the ship was
stationary going at 50 knots or 50 000
however if this was true something else
had to give and the only freedom in the
equations was the very nature of space
and time themselves for it to work each
Observer must have their own measurement
of space and each Observer must have
their own measurements of time
with special relativity it was the speed
of light that was absolute not space and
time space and time were no longer the
universal stage on which physics played
out and just as Maxwell had combined
electricity and magnetism
space time too was about to unite
[Music]
gentlemen the views of space and time
which I wish to lay before you they are
radical henceforth Space by itself and
Time by itself are doomed to fade away
into mere shadows and only a kind of
Union of the two will preserve an
independent reality
in 1908 Hermann minkowsky Einstein's
former Professor came up with an idea in
reaction to the revelations of special
relativity in 1905 he had decided to
explore the geometry of these new
equations in Einstein's formulation
space was space and time was time and to
transform from one observer's Viewpoint
to another you needed to mix the two
together but minkowski pointed out that
it was simpler to mix space and time
together into space-time and to
transform one observer's space-time to
another through geometry and so finally
combined space-time was born this new
melding of the three dimensions of space
and one dimension of time has come to be
known as minkowski space though
minkowski himself tragically died in
1909 before his idea had been fully
embraced by the physics Community
Newtonian space and time may have been
completely upended but Einstein was
still not happy though his ideas had
revolutionized our ideas of the universe
they could not account for gravity
Newton's gravitational equations needed
the distance between masses and special
relativity now told us that no one could
even agree on what these distances were
so Einstein went back to the drawing
board and spent a decade thinking about
gravity
[Music]
would eventually emerged from these
ruminations in 1915 was a solution that
shocked physics to its core Einstein had
taken minkowski's geometric picture of
space-time and made both space and time
bendy and stretchy the presence of mass
and energy producing this curvature
within this general theory Einstein
concluded that gravity as a force simply
did not exist the effects of gravity
were encoded within the curvature of
space and time Newton's picture of space
and time was well and truly dead for Not
only was space and time relative they
were flexible as well the consequences
of Einstein's vision of Relativity were
quickly uncovered in the special Theory
the relative ticks of clocks depended on
motion and whilst everyone feels time
passing at one second per second
different clocks will tick off different
amounts of time but with the coming of
the general theory time was shaken even
more as where you are also influences
The Tick of your clock the presence of
mass curved space and curves time and so
gravity can dictate the relative ticking
of a clock
the following year in 1916 Carl
schwarzshield solved the field equations
of Relativity for a spherical mass and
written inside his equations was a
completely collapsed Mass squeezed into
a point whilst it didn't get its name
for another 50 years schwartzshield had
the mathematics for a black hole his
solution showed the black holes Bend
both space and time and with this
intense curvature comes intense
gravitational pulls not even light able
to escape in the vicinity of a black
hole where gravitational fields are
immense time becomes more and more
curved as you get closer to the center
compared to clocks in the distant
Universe near the Heart of Darkness time
ticks very slowly
and it wasn't just black holes that
sprung from the new equations
in the centuries since Einstein's
gravitational insights many more bizarre
Solutions have been found throughout the
relativistic literature there are
wormholes warp drives and even entire
curved universes all built from the
malleable nature of space and time
in 1919 observations of the deflection
of Starlight proved his theory and made
Einstein a superstar and so scientists
turned their attention to measuring the
effects of general relativity to further
cement the concept
foreign
one of the weirdest of these experiments
was undertaken by Joseph haffel and
Richard Keating in 1971. their equipment
was a series of very accurate cesium
clocks and a set of Jet Plane Journeys
that completely encircled the Earth to
begin the experiment all the clocks were
placed in the same location and
synchronized some of the clocks then
headed off on a plane some heading to
the East and others to the West some
moving with the Earth's rotation others
against it seven thousand six hundred
dollars was spent on flights with two
seats on each plane going to Mr clock
and because they were flying they were
in a different gravitational field to
the clocks Left Behind after they had
circled the world twice they were all
brought together if the universe was
governed by Newton's absolute time they
should all have remained in sync but if
Einstein was correct relative motions
and space-time curvature should have d
synced them the experiment was run and
the clocks were reunited they differed
by a few hundred nanoseconds
Einstein was declared the winner
but there is one more test of Relativity
that has proven to be the most
spectacular
in developing relativity Einstein found
a stretchy space-time can also wobble
and ring just as Maxwell founded
electricity and magnetism could Ripple
so could gravity but Einstein couldn't
decide if his mathematics were correct
or if he was fooling himself and
struggled to conclude whether these
gravitational waves were a part of
reality
in 1974 Russell Hulse was a young
astronomy student who made a spectacular
Discovery with his supervisor Joseph
Taylor whilst peering into the universe
with the 300 meter Arecibo telescope he
found a pulsar the rapidly spinning dead
heart of a star this Pulsar PSR
b1913-16 was spinning 17 times a second
and was not on its own but orbited
another dead star heart a neutron star
and with the regular beats of the Pulsar
they were able to accurately chart the
cosmic dance what they found however was
quite unexpected with Newtonian gravity
these dead stars should orbit each other
for eternity but Taylor and Hulse
founded the orbits were shrinking and
the stars were slowly but steadily being
drawn together somehow the energy of
their orbits was leaking out into the
universe and it was then Taylor and
Hulse realized Einstein's gravitational
waves were an ideal culprit they delved
into the mathematics of general
relativity and calculated how the
orbiting stars formed ripples in
space-time showing how they could carry
away precisely enough energy to explain
the orbital demise in 1993 Taylor and
Hulse received the Nobel Prize for their
Discovery and 24 years later the prize
was awarded for the direct detection of
gravitational waves that experiment was
the laser interferometer gravitational
wave Observatory or simply ligo for
short which with unimagined sensitivity
can feel the tiny ripples of space-time
ligo has opened a new and exciting
window on the universe they are
uncovering merging black holes and the
collisions between neutron stars and now
astronomers even planned to hunt for the
oldest gravitational waves formed in the
birth of the universe
and so in this new world ushered in by
Einstein it is clear that the entire
Cosmos is written in the language of
gravity of curved and warped space and
time
but
there was one more secret to uncover
hidden in the equations first realized
by Alexander Friedman in 1922 and later
proved by Edwin Hubble the expansion of
the universe is the expansion of space
expanding from a single point 13.8
billion years ago known today as the Big
Bang put very simply there was less
space yesterday
and there will be more space tomorrow
every galaxy has been found to be moving
further and further away from us by our
local group at an average rate of 70
kilometers a second per megaparsec which
actually means that at the moment for
every 3.26 million light years distance
away from us a Galaxy is it is moving
away from us at an extra 70 kilometers a
second so a Galaxy 326 million light
years from us is moving at 7 000
kilometers a second and the Galaxy
32.6 billion light years away it recedes
from us faster than the speed of light
this may seem bizarre after everything
we have learned up until this point but
the universe's speed limit only applies
to objects moving through space and
these galaxies are not moving through
space away from us
space is simply growing between us
this expanding Universe makes curving
and bending space-time even more
complicated to understand as equations
show that space is infinite what is
actually happening is that the universe
is becoming less dense and clearly this
decrease in density is not completely
uniform across the cosmos you for
example are not slowly drifting apart
individual galaxies too hold themselves
together due to their Mutual gravity but
as this gravity is a manifestation of
the curvature of space what happens at
the boundary between expanding and
non-expanding space
and that is not the only problem as
expanding space makes the form of
yesterday's space-time different to
tomorrow's space-time thus breaking what
was thought to be one of the Key
properties of the universe conservation
of energy
the importance of symmetry in physics
was laid out in detail by mathematician
Emmy nurtur in this case a symmetry
meaning that when you change your
situation the physics Remains the Same
changing location doesn't change physics
meaning momentum is conserved and the
fact that physics is the same today and
tomorrow gives energy conservation but
in an expanding Universe where
space-time is changing this symmetry is
shattered as space grows it doesn't
stretch it doesn't dilute there is just
more of it but as photons travel across
an expanding Universe they are stretched
and they lose energy and galaxies are
robbed of their speed as their motion
grinds to a halt
in this way energy is simply not
conserved as the cosmos grows
a conundrum that causes problems for
physicists to this day
[Music]
and so it may now seem that space has
finally become physical real after all
it can bend expand curve and ripple
but there is a final twist one final
Rock to be pulled out from beneath us
and this can be summed up in the words
of the Nobel Prize winner Stephen
Weinberg
how is it possible for space which is
utterly empty to expand how can nothing
expand
the answer is space does not expand
cosmologists sometimes talk about
expanding space but they should know
better
to the novice this statement must seem
almost bizarre how can a leading
scientist make such a claim
well because he is absolutely correct in
Einstein's relativity space-time is
truly nothing the mathematics look like
bending and curving but in reality
relativity tells us space is nothing and
has no properties
foreign
in this new picture
just how were seconds minutes and hours
affected by the dawn of relativity
to the Future civilization time meant
many things
they knew that their time was unique
unshared by any others they understood
that clocks ticked differently depending
on where you were and what you were
doing their Engineers had used this
malleable nature of space-time in
shaping their civilization great portals
of distorted time and space permitted
travel across the Empire whilst the slow
ticks near the gravitational pull of a
black hole had been used to stretch time
and allow them to watch the end of
everything
People Like Us that believe in physics
know that the distinction between past
present and future is only a stubbornly
persistent illusion
with the coming of Einstein's general
relativity physicists were presented
with a new headache they knew that every
particle in the universe had a past
present and future and like a lion drawn
on a map they could chart the Journey of
a particle through the four dimensions
of space and time tracing out its
individual World line from the past to
the Future through a series of Nows each
particle in your body each electron and
Quark Journeys on its own world line
before you were conceived the world
lines were dispersed but as you grew
many world lines condensed into a bundle
which is you and when you are gone these
World lines will again scatter for a
fleeting moment in the life of the
universe you exist as little more than a
collection of worldlines a brief not in
the fabric of Eternity
whilst unsettling this appears to make
sense so where is the headache
firstly we have to remember what the
relativity of time really means with no
absolute time there is no uniform Cosmic
clock and this means that there is no
such thing as a unique present a true
instant of now without an absolute
definition of a cosmic now just how do
we Define a unique notion of the past
just where does the future begin
and so headache within the equations of
Relativity all pasts presence and
Futures are already written the entire
history of all things is already out
there somewhere this notion known as the
block Universe has bothered many
physicists and philosophers as without a
now the cosmos simply cannot unfold from
moment to moment all we can do is we
Trace out our world line is follow our
predefined path and the concepts dear to
us such as free will a lost
foreign
but this cannot be correct we clearly
remember the past and the future is a
mysterious door that is yet to be opened
they are clearly different
or are they
consider two electrons hurtling towards
each other both carry an identical
negative charge and through
electromagnetism they repel as they get
closer the repulsion grows and their
motion gradually slows stops and
reverses eventually the electrons hurtle
away from each other back the way they
came there seems nothing strange about
this
but imagine we filmed the interaction
between the two electrons and then
showed the film to an audience of
physicists playing a mirrored version
the left switch to right and vice versa
your audience of physicists would notice
nothing amiss with the movie on the
screen switching left and right does not
alter the physics
but what if you went one step further
what if you were very clumsy and instead
of switching left and right you switched
past and future the film now runs
backwards time has been reversed your
audience stares at the screen
what do they see in this time reversed
movie two electrons hurtle towards each
other they get closer and closer with
their repulsion growing eventually they
halt in their motion and start to move
away again
and with nothing out of the ordinary the
audience nods in approval but this
simple display of physics
now is this possible if you would run
the slapstick of Laurel and Hardy
backwards the viewers would have noticed
and would immediately know that
something was wrong with the arrow of
time
and herein lies the question why is the
electromagnetic interaction between
electrons insensitive to the direction
of time and not just electromagnetism
with gravity and the strong nuclear
force are also unaffected the weak
nuclear force does misbehave slightly
but it is a very tiny effect it seems
that at their core the universe's
microscopic fundamental interactions do
not possess an arrow of time time could
flow one way or the other and they
simply wouldn't care
this leaves us with a disconnect
the macroscopic large-scale world we
inhabit certainly does know about time
cooling coffee burning wood exploding
supernovae these are not processes that
can simply be run backwards you cannot
unscramble an egg
but with a little thought this seems
strange
clearly our large-scale world is nothing
more than the collective properties of
an uncountable number of atoms and these
atoms are interacting through a
fundamental Force electromagnetism each
of the Myriad of electromagnetic
interactions unaffected by the direction
of time so how can such an arrow emerge
from the multitude of time ignorant
interactions that take place every
second how does time emerge
in the simple view of the block Universe
it stretches infinitely far into the
past and infinitely far into the future
but this block Universe clearly doesn't
appear to resemble our own for we know
that our universe didn't stretch
infinitely into the past it had a
beginning from observations we know that
the Universe was born almost 14 billion
years ago we don't know the process that
brought it into being but it was born
with both space and time just where and
how space and time came to be in the
universe remains a mystery but they have
remained an integral part of the cosmos
since its Inception
and there are other mysteries about the
birth of the universe that we don't
understand in particular it appeared to
be extremely special being both hot and
dense and strangely smooth
[Music]
and this smoothness meant that the
newborn Universe had a very particular
property
the universe was born with very low
entropy
it might seem strange that smoothness
implies low entropy as a gas spread
throughout a room has higher entropy
than gas all squeezed in one corner but
for MATA in the universe this smoothness
meant gravity could do its work and fall
together eventually clumping into stars
and galaxies and so as the universe
expands its entropy increases as the
matter evolves gravitational potential
energy is steadily converted into stars
planets and people eventually this
energy is processed into waste heat that
spreads throughout the Universe and it
is this change from low to higher
entropy that imprints onto the cosmos
its Arrow of time
recent Nobel Prize winner sir Roger
Penrose has thought hard about our
universe's initial entropy he has
concluded that the probability of this
occurring by chance is one part in 10 to
the 10 to the 123.
clearly there must have been something
special about our universe's birth
but what this was we still don't know
and so would this mean that the block
Universe has no innate Arrow of time
without the Big Bang would it be
impossible to distinguish the past from
the future imagining how we would
experience such a universe is very
difficult to do but indeed maybe our
ability to imagine anything at all is
ultimately because of the special birth
of the universe
foreign
on the 10th of June 1944 a British
Halifax bomber was flying over France
with 400 other bombers it was supporting
the D-Day Landings at Normandy but near
the city of Laval the aircraft was
struck by German flag and crashed in
Flames into the French Countryside
the entire crew perished in the crash
seven lives were lost seven lives in a
war that eventually claimed Millions
the pilot was a 33 year old Dutch
volunteer William Jacob van stockm and
whilst his name is not familiar today
van stockham was the man who discovered
time travel
of course by the 1940s time travel was a
staple of Science Fiction The Time
Machine by H.G Wells had been published
half a century earlier but this was all
fantasy and Whimsy and a firm
impossibility in Newtonian space and
time yet within the new world of
Relativity van stockum had discovered a
scientific basis
mathematically relativity is notoriously
challenging Einstein himself had
wondered if his field equations would
yield any analytic Solutions but merely
a year after presenting them to the
world the first such solution was found
a smart Shield derived his black holes
and so by the 1920s the hunt was on for
the mathematical form of the entire
universe
along with the Giants of Relativity
Einstein Friedman de sitter and others
laying down rules finding expanding
space which itself could be curved and
even space where parallel lines could
converge and diverge some scientists
explored the mathematics of hypothetical
universes and Hungarian mathematician
Cornelius lanthos had found a rather
peculiar solution his equations describe
the universe of dust that was rigidly
rotating and whilst it didn't appear to
describe our actual Universe it was an
intriguing result van stockum began to
wonder about the Journey of particles
through such a rotating universe as
these particles traveled from the past
to the Future World lines stretched
around the universe but as the universe
rotated time and space was stretched and
distorted some World lines stretched
right around the universe and met
themselves forming closed Loops along
these the future trod over the path of
the past over and over again physicists
call these closed-loop worldlines
time-like paths
but in everyday language it was nothing
less than time travel
that space and time can be so warped as
to allow time travel was shocking and
whilst the rotating Universe might not
be physically realistic it opened up the
question of whether there were other
routes to the Past
or Shortcuts To The Future
van stockham's goal was to head to
Princeton to work directly with Einstein
but as the clouds of War were gathering
he looked back to Europe once his
homeland was occupied his desire was to
get into the fight
and Van Stockholm's own world line ended
in a French field on a dark night in
1944
whilst van Stockholm's name has now lost
to history time travel and rotating
universes are not as they were
rediscovered by The Eccentric
mathematician Kurt Google in 1949
googlers remember today as one of the
greatest logicians of all time and his
famous incompleteness theorem still
baffles today but his contributions to
physics were equally shocking escaping
the turmoil in Europe as the storm cloud
of the second world war gathered unlike
van stockum Google did reach Princeton
University and it was there he and
Einstein became firm friends with
Einstein supporting his application for
American citizenship specifically by
driving him to the hearing and
distracting him from pointing out flaws
in the United States Constitution to the
judge seeing his case
it was at Princeton that Google turned
his remarkable mathematical mind to
relativity and the nature of space-time
and in 1949 Google's 70th birthday
present to Einstein was a solution to
the field equations of Relativity like
van stockm he had found the mathematics
of a rotating universe and closed
time-like curves that looped around his
Cosmos on receiving his present Einstein
was in his own words disturbed by the
possibility
Google's wife had apparently knitted him
a sweater too but it was not part of the
final gift history does not record why
Einstein died soon after in 1955 and
Google followed him in 1978. in his
later years Google asked astronomers if
they had found the universe was truly
rotating the answer was always no it
isn't and that Google's universe is not
our own
but the possibility that Einstein's
relativity potentially allowed time
travel sent researchers back to their
equations
foreign
space really Bend back on themselves so
far as to allow temporal exploration
physicists have continued to find
mathematical shortcuts through space and
time and there are now many solutions to
Einstein's equations in which space and
time are extremely warped
it would seem that in Einstein's
relativity time travel remains a
stubborn theoretical possibility
as an example if you add spin to a black
hole space and time twirl also and if
you dive right through the center you
might emerge somewhere and some when
else another relativistic structure a
wormhole builds a space-time bridge
between two locations and potentially
between two different times but not
necessarily a shortcut
the reality of these Solutions whether
they can truly exist remains unanswered
perhaps we will never be able to focus
enough energy into a single place for
space-time to bend right back on itself
We Now understand how Einstein's
space-time works but we still don't know
what it is where can we turn next
it was not just Einstein who was
charting A New Path at the beginning of
the 20th century it was a dramatic
period for theoretical physics and
quantum mechanics was at the Forefront
of the changing order
and so perhaps physicists thought the
answer could lie at the smallest scales
in the universe
in the far future
the civilization had become desperate
Stars had long died and matter itself
was starting to melt
very few remained now almost Frozen in
the darkness the last of Life grinding
to a halt but some eyes still peered
into the skies to witness the last
bursts of light in the universe the
great books had told them this time
would come warning them the not even
black holes would last forever whilst
the immense gravity of Relativity held
them together on the smallest scale the
action of the quantum World resulted in
their ultimate Decay
for eons they had struggled to combine
the two the world of gravity had seemed
so distant from the quantum
and so too their black hole home was
dissolving
they could do nothing to stop it
the last few were so very tired they
didn't even try
a university student attending lectures
on general relativity in the morning and
others on quantum mechanics in the
afternoon might be forgiven for thinking
that his professors are fools or have
neglected to communicate with each other
for at least a century
there is a grave at Rose Lawn Cemetery
in Tallahassee Florida written on it is
the name of a man who died in 1984 aged
82. unlike others in the graveyard the
man also has a plaque at Westminster
Abbey in London not far from the Mortal
remains of Isaac Newton this plaque does
not say much it labels the man as a
physicist and notes his birth and death
but on the plaque is also an equation a
complex mix of Latin and Greek letters
and this equation was the first
unification of Einstein's relativity
and quantum mechanics
famous physicist Niels Bohr referred to
Paul Adrian Maurice Dirac as the
strangest man to visit his Institute
born in Bristol at the beginning of the
20th century he did not at first seem
destined for scientific greatness in
1923 Dirac began his studies at the
University of Cambridge famously focused
on his science he shunned many human
interactions and his conversations were
mainly silent his colleagues went as far
as to name the unit of one word per hour
as a Dirac in his honor but whilst his
speech was slow his mind raced around
the problems of physics
it was a heady time to be a physicist
with both Einstein's new world of
Relativity and the bizarre implications
of quantum mechanics opening up were the
fundamental secrets of the universe
finally revealing themselves
when Iraq began his exploration of
quantum mechanics It Was Written in the
past the mathematics of Schrodinger and
Heisenberg played out on the stage of
Newton with the tick of an absolute
clock and Galileo's vision of space
but Dirac knew that this picture of
space and time was simply outdated
surely the equations of quantum
mechanics should reflect Einstein's New
Visions of space and time this bothered
Iraq and he scrambled with the
mathematics trying to make it work
spending his Sundays walking alone
turning over the equations in his mind
and in December 1927 the fog began to
clear
a relativistic Quantum equation came
into view an equation that obeyed
Einstein's demand that there is no
special rest in the universe and Iraq
used this equation to explain the
simplest of particles
the electron
suddenly various peculiar properties of
the electron made mathematical sense
within dirac's equation the electron
spins and behaves like a small bar
magnet both properties had been
difficult to explain but they were a
natural consequence of Relativity and
there was another property that was
completely unexpected if you take the
square root of 1 there are two Solutions
Plus One or minus one in the same way in
explaining the electron the Dirac
equation has two solutions one solution
is negatively charged and clearly
represents the electron but just what
does the positive solution correspond to
at First Direct wondered if it could be
the proton the positively charged
particle within the nucleus but being
almost 2 000 times more massive that
could not be correct he eventually
concluded his equation was predicting a
brand new particle the anti-electron
this particle should have the same mass
as the electron but have the opposite
positive charge
antimatter
[Music]
the Dirac equation was the birth of
quantum field Theory the most successful
physical Theory it is with these
mathematics that scientists can describe
nearly all of the fundamental particles
and forces the basis of the Modern
Standard model
and for each of these particles there
are anti-particles electrons positrons
quarks and anti-quarks all are
consequence of Einstein's view of
relative space and relative time
but Quantum field theory is built on
Einstein's special theory of relativity
what of gravity and the general theory
of relativity what if we incorporate
curved space-time into the Dirac
equation
unfortunately after such incredible
early success the last century has
brought us no further in this Quest
with Quantum field Theory the quantum
wave function that underlies existence
still plays out within the arena of
space and time because of special
relativity this space-time is more
complex than Newton's view but space and
time are still the universal stage and
this stage is broken when considering
the curved space-time of general
relativity
remember in the general theory of
relativity space and time are Dynamic
and evolving they are not simply the
stage they are players in the physics of
the universe quantum mechanics was
complicated enough but after many years
of work its various Infinities had
ultimately been tamed with curving
bending Rippling space-time the
Infinities seemed uncontrollable
with this failure to Simply merge
gravity and quantum mechanics some
physicists have searched elsewhere this
has involved going back to the drawing
board with brand new ideas for just what
space and time are in the Quest for the
so-called Theory of Everything the so
far fruitless search to tie the
microscopic Quantum world to the
macroscopic world of general relativity
and fully explain the universe
but of course these theories of
everything have not necessarily made
things simpler
in one of the leading contenders string
or M Theory there might be 11 or even 26
Dimensions but what do these ideas have
to say about the fundamental nature of
time and space
again it's not so simple in M Theory
space and time are part of the
fundamental structures of the universe
the strange contorted shape of the
structure in multiple Dimensions
explains everything not just space and
time but all matter all radiation and
all the forces what exactly are these
fundamental structures made of M Theory
doesn't tell us another Contender for
The Theory of Everything Is Loop quantum
gravity on the face of it this theory is
even more bizarre with space and time
being Quantum phenomena at the smallest
possible scale space-time is chunky
fundamentally meshed together into a
network and to us this subatomic mesh
has the appearance of smooth space and
time but again we can ask what are these
Quantum grains made of
and again we are left disappointed as
they just are
but perhaps the solution is simpler than
this
perhaps some have speculated
space and time do not exist
at
all
remember at the start of this story we
heard about the disagreement between
Newton and leibnuts to Newton space and
time were part of reality and existed
independent of the matter in the
universe leibnitz however said that it
was the relationships between Mata the
defined space and time without them
space and time would have no meaning and
the relativistic vision of space-time
seemed to match this picture Einstein
told us that Mata defined the structure
of space-time and space-time told Mata
what to do we know that in the quantum
picture space-time appears to be lumpy
and the reality is possibly constructed
of these bits of space-time as the
universe grows
but what if space and time
are not really there what if space and
time are actually emergent phenomena
something we experience only as
macroscopic beings
this might sound strange but we know
that we are sandwiched in the universe
this means that for example we don't
feel the cosmological expansion that
dominates the large-scale universe and
similarly we don't feel the individual
atoms as they collide with our skin
instead we have a collective term
temperature to describe what is
happening perhaps space and time are the
same
in 1997 Juan malda Cena found a key
relationship in the mathematics of
string theory and gravity known as the
ads CFT correspondence it could be
accidental and of no consequence but it
could also be pointing to something
deeper the path to uniting quantum
mechanics and gravity but if this is the
right path something else emerges
through this relationship space and time
become granular pieces of fundamental
length and fundamental time
Planck scale pixels that set the
smallest resolution of the universe
this would mean that at the smallest
scales space and time would appear as
nothing more than grains of sand
on a beach
[Music]
and so perhaps there is no space between
the grains of reality no time between
one grain and another perhaps to these
grains these are Concepts that make no
sense there are only their relations how
they interact
for us much larger than the scale of
these grains there is the concept of
space and somehow through the
relationships of the grains we
experience the experience of experience
but underlying this may be ultimately
space and time simply don't exist
and there are just fundamental bits and
pieces
and they're into relationships
[Music]
this may feel uncomfortable just where
is the you in this relational universe
Perhaps it is best to think of it like
this most of us have come to terms with
the fact that we are physically a
collection of atoms we our Consciousness
somehow emerges we seem to be able to
live with this illusion of our being
maybe all we need to do is the same for
the stage on which we play out our
existence
[Music]
and so we have come a long way and are
approaching the end of our journey space
and time our Focus along our path both
seemed so natural so normal but we have
discovered that they are far more
strange more mysterious than they first
appear
though the space and time of Newton was
simple and absolute they became far more
complex with Einstein's curving
space-time and the quantum nature of
space-time attempts to dice space and
time into little pieces but are we
really any closer to understanding its
true nature
a lot of Hope is pinned on our next
fundamental theories that The Theory of
Everything will eventually shine a light
on the universal stage and maybe written
into that theory will be the true nature
of space and time perhaps the block
universe will be banished as the cosmos
unfolds perhaps Quantum processes are
constructing a now one instant at a time
or perhaps some process we have yet to
imagine is defining reality
of course nature is not bound to reveal
its Secrets no matter how hard
scientists work they may never reveal
the fundamental truth we must face the
fact that some Mysteries might remain
forever mysterious
indeed just what space and time actually
are could forever be beyond our grasp
[Music]
and so finally we return to the Twilight
of the cosmos
within their home the last few watched
their black hole slowly evaporate
all they wanted was to eke out one more
day one more moment
but eventually the decay of the universe
could no longer be shut out
they had manipulated space they had
mastered time
but they could not defeat them
and then
there was Darkness
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think thanks for watching and
we'll see you
next time
[Music]